you work with a lot of young artists
right
you work with folks um writing and
processing and
trying to put worship music out into the
world yeah
often i think if i think of worship
music
and you distill it down it's what are
the things burning holes in people right
now
and when you talk to young people their
ambitions
you can kind of step back and see what
are their gods right now yeah so as you
work with young people
as you work with trying to that bridge
to connect with audiences
when you listen to what they are looping
on what their dreams are what their
fears are
and you've got a house full of kids
right
what are a couple of things you're
seeing just out in the world
that bring you joy what a couple things
you're seeing that make you really
uncomfortable
i mean i am really blessed with an
amazing community
i believe that the best work only comes
from community
um i was really just lucky or the lord
smiled at me or whatever to have sort of
found a really great community
super early on that i'm still super
tight with and we work together
all the time yeah you know 20 20 some
years now we've been
and all of our roles are different but
it's still the same people
um and that's been a real joy and
um one of the things that's given me the
most joy is being in this position now
where i get to sort of invite people to
the table
but what i get what i do is i sort of
set the table
and then i get to back away and hope
that they become friends
and it's been fun to watch some of them
create
themselves and there's a little fomo
because i want to be in it
right because you know it's like oh i'm
like but i'm a coach now i'm not a
player
and um and it's been really it's been
wonderful to watch these
this community grow and one of my
colleagues
there's a dear friend uh he calls the
work we do relationship farming
wow you sort of plant seeds and you tend
it
but the lord's gonna make things grow
and and
i'm not if i'm chasing sort of the hit
uh
then i'm trying to i'm trying to use
people but when
when i just bring wonderful people
together and try to serve them
then they make wonderful things that
will get hits
but that's that's not the point that's a
byproduct of
that's a byproduct of it so by us
building by us trying to
to really build a healthy community of
people
that we serve well um that equips a lot
of communities
around the world you know and they'll
make things that will serve people and
that's really been beautiful
what what are you hearing from young
artists from young musicians
that makes your heart skip like you all
need to solve this man
right you all need to get onto this
oh man um i don't know man i just i feel
like there's a real
um i can go so deep into this and i
don't know we don't have time but
um there are these generational arcs in
the way that the church
tends to work um where you had
the jesus people and then you had the
mega church and then you had the kids
that grew up in the mega church
that are the you know millennials in gen
z or gen x and they had kids
and now the young artists
and the young people are the kids of the
millennials of
like they're the grandkids of the mega
church
and uh so you're seeing an embrace of
uh of less scripted
worship less scripted interaction with
things they don't want to be programmed
or they don't want to be sold to they
don't want to be marketed to
they just want to be with huh and the
church is growing a lot smaller
among people that age and what i'm what
i mean by that is not a number of people
actually but they don't want to meet in
groups of three five thousand they don't
want to be a number
they want to meet in somebody's living
room and they want to be known it's just
what we talked about the other stuff and
so
uh most of the young artists that i work
with are in deep intentional communities
of 50 100 200 people they come in these
small churches and they're doing just
beautiful work because they're writing
songs
for my friend who just lost their mom
and not
to try to get on the radio gotcha right
and so when that song gets on the radio
oh man that's fun and then i hear it
driving down the road
and i just lose a buddy yeah and then
somebody
just puts a a lightning bolt into my
heart
because they're writing to somebody and
that somebody
happened to yeah look a lot like me
right yeah it's
it's so that's when you get magic man
yeah well dude i'm so grateful
that you're now the player coach the
only thing
the only challenge with that analogy is
there's got to be moments like when
you're
a coach coach like i can't jump like
that anymore i'm old my knees don't work
you have to sit there on the sidelines
sometimes be like i could play that
better than that guy
i know number one you should not be
playing a jazz master because
why is that guitar even made and two
that's an inside joke he's got one
um and two i could probably play that
better than you but i gotta let it go
let it be out there that that could be a
challenge sometimes
it's gratitude right i guess but it's
fun when they get when you help them get
it that's the fun thing
is it their awesome i just get to see
you at the rhyme and sit off into the
wings just like with your gratitude
journal like i'm grateful for this
opportunity to just watching
somebody just go kill it oh it's
wonderful